what more needs to be done in your view
well we have done really well with
vaccination in this country
and we're in a almost a unique position
as as britain having vaccinated large
numbers of people
with both pfizer which is a messenger
rna vaccine
and astrazeneca which is an antivirus
vaccine
and therefore we have the data
of both vaccines how they've worked
how many people after the each
vaccination
how many people have been still
diagnosed with covert how many people
have those been hospitalized how many of
those
have died so we have i think that data
and my view is that if we publish that
data
obviously going to be careful how you
publish it you've got to publish it in a
form that that tells people the truth
about the vaccines
but if you publish that data it will
have a major impact on restoring the
credibility of astrozenica worldwide
we don't have a problem with astrazeneca
here but worldwide countries
are either refusing astrazeneca for
certain categories of people
or you even get countries in africa now
refusing the backseat
this is completely unjustified i think
the full data set will show that
astrazeneca
is a highly effective vaccine it will
save
huge amounts of lives hospitalization
and people getting long covert so it's
really important
then we have as a country a huge
interest in this because
even if we get ourselves vaccinated if
the virus is still mutating in different
parts of the world then the risk is
there
that you get a mutation comes back into
the uk and vaccines may be less
effective against it
well but how do we get that message
across because i mean a lot i mean
i think it was denmark who banned it all
together a week or so ago
i mean these are countries with you know
some solid
scientific backgrounds that their
scientists are looking at this now
if they're saying they're not happy to
use it how do we convince them otherwise
well i think you convince them by as i
say putting out the full data set so in
israel for example with the pfizer
vaccine
you can see a chart that says numbers
vaccinated
of those who are vaccinated one dose two
dose how many got covered how many of
those were hospitalized how many died
and the the results are remarkable now i
believe
we will have exactly the same results
for astrazeneca indeed buried away in
some of the
slides of the the mhra in this country
are what people have done is
self-reporting after
having vaccination and the figures for
astrazeneca and visa are roughly the
same and they're both dramatically good
by the way
so i think if you put out the full data
set it will have an impact
and yes it's true that some regulators
in countries like denmark
are taking this view but they're taking
it frankly on
unjustified and an unbalanced view of
the material
and the european medical agency which is
the equivalent for europe of our mhra
they're not taking the same view so one
other thing that we suggest in this
report is just a whole lot of things
that
the government might do to make the data
more accessible for people
but one of the things we need to do is
for the leading countries of the world
to put their regulators
together their top scientists together
so that they can pronounce on some of
these issues
and so that you don't get different
regulators taking different decisions of
different countries
often on a very very narrow view of risk
well look whereas i'm sure a lot of
people would agree with you there is
there still is this it's a known risk
when it comes to to astrazeneca
and we know when you look at the figures
it is an absolutely tiny risk but you
know what it's like to deal with big
figures and then to have to
you know face people individual people
affected by this
but what would you say to those people
indeed in the uk
who have lost a loved one to a blood
clot caused by a vaccine
yeah so of course any loss of life is
terrible and tragic and
you know of course our sympathy and our
hearts go out to the people
who have suffered but the point is
you're much
much more likely to be at risk of covid
than you are of a blood clot
and probably over the next few weeks we
will we will have a better understanding
of those very rare cases
of blood clots how we might prevent them
but the chances of
of getting such a plot is about one in
250
000 and you know if you take for example
oral contraception
the chances are more like one and two
thousand so you
if you if you take a a proper view of
risk you're
much much more likely to suffer as a
result of covid
than you are with these very very small
numbers of cases
around blood clots and one of the
problems i mean we'll publish a paper in
the next few weeks
showing how you could vaccinate the
world the whole of the world
this year and i tell you why i think
that's going to be
a vital prerequisite for government
around the world to come together and
try and do
is that this vaccine this virus is
mutating all the time
i mean just in india alone you've got
several hundred mutations
just in these last weeks now most of
those will be insignificant
but some of them may be significant and
so your risk is if you're not
careful and you don't get on with this
vaccination program
then you're going to get a mutation
against which the vaccines
are much less or effective or
ineffective and
just remember astrazeneca along with the
other
antivirus backseat johnson johnson
they're cheaper
they're the ones that the developing
world will use and if they're
discredited for any reason
the whole of the global um program for
vaccination is going to get slowed down
and disrupted so this is really really
important and our government
has got a huge interest in getting these
facts out there
and getting people to realize it's a
good vaccine
an excellent vaccine and one that should
be used globally
um can we change uh subject if you're
okay with that talk about the green sill
inquiry now you're going to be called
before
one of the inquiries at least aren't you
i mean what is your take on where we are
currently in terms of
of the lobbying situation are we still
in the situation we were
back in your days in number 10 or has
there been much
change since then i think it's probably
been quite a lot of
change because of the the ways people
communicate with each other and i was
saying someone earlier
um today you know i didn't have a mobile
phone when i was prime minister
um so you know the issues of texting
didn't arise i mean obviously it's a
different world today
and look i think all of this is going to
be looked at it should be looked at
um and you know i'm perfectly having to
cooperate in any way anyone wants but
it's
it's i think you just the best thing
with these
types of situation is to get them looked
into thoroughly you come up with a set
of rules
that make sense and and mean that you
know
people have confidence in the system
going forward i mean
so you didn't get when you were you
think you didn't get any text messages
from people asking for a quiet word but
you may have had a
a phone call or a letter i mean it is
that
fundamentally wrong is it sleazy as the
labour party is now calling it
look there's nothing wrong with
receiving representations for people
from people and you know something
actually wrong with lobbying
i mean lobbying's a sort of loaded word
but
you know people in in in government of
course they should receive
information what's necessary is that the
decision making process
then is obviously done in an objective
way and
i think by and large you know in our
system it is i mean i think we've got to
be
careful of overstating the problems
within our
our own system by and large the british
system is a pretty clean system
but you know yes of course as a result
of what's happening
happening people want to look at the
rules they should do um and then let's
see what they come out with
um look i know we're running out of time
i want to ask you a couple about a
couple of issues
first and foremost johnny mercer who's
resigned or been pushed whichever way
you want to view it really
as veterans minister he's very concerned
about the way where
we're looking after our veterans and the
veterans pledge to
to remove people from investigation
after a significant
period of time now you've had a very
close relationship
with the armed forces some good some bad
we don't need to sort of reiterate all
of that but do you think it is
you know right that we do provide our
armed forces
with some better safeguards once they
become veterans
i think so yes because they're they're
doing an incredibly difficult job
they're doing it on behalf of the
country they're putting their lives on
the line
for us for our protection and our
security and so
you know obviously again you've got to
have proper rules in place but
you know my my instinct is always to try
and protect
um service men and women and and to give
them every support
i mean clearly mr mercer's sort of
concern is primarily at this stage about
those
in their 70s and 80s who serve tours in
northern ireland do you think the
government has failed them
well the government's failed them but i
think it's really important we take
account of the fact
that these are people who are operating
in incredibly difficult circumstances
and you know as i say my basic
disposition is to be as
as protective of them as possible and as
as helpful as possible because
you know you've got to be really careful
when
when people are in combat situations
they're having to take decisions
very very fast you know their own lives
are at risk and
and there are people that are trying to
attack them
you've got to be understanding of that
situation and not try and superimpose
um you know a view based on on
circumstances that that may be
completely unrealistic
given the the types of challenges that
those people were facing so
no i essentially i'm
i would be wanting to be supportive of
them look i know we're almost out of
time but can i just quickly ask you
about george floyd and
the situation in the united states since
2016 the united states has become a more
divided country new administration now
and then this significant verdict in the
george floyd
trial do we i mean do you get the
impression that things
are starting to to significantly change
in the united states that some of those
divisions are starting to heal
look the verdict i think is
it's a turning point i think it's a
really important verdict
and it's important also that people
remember that some of the most
persuasive testimony in that case came
from other police officers
and indeed from senior police officers
in that police force
saying that what happened was completely
against their own rules
so i i mean i hope it is a turning point
um in in the relationship
between uh the black community in the us
and
and
the police whether it heals the
divisions in american society i don't
know
those divisions run pretty deep i think
but let's hope it is because it's
important for all
modern western societies that they try
and resolve these issues in a way that
brings people together